hi I'm Justine and I'm Karen and
together we'll be travelling the US only
problem is we have no idea where we're
going parent Justine thank you for
joining us we have a very special event
planned for you tonight if you can make
it well he got so intense it was kind of
scary like are we gonna be stuck here
forever
if you're not on time we won't let you
in and you're already running late I'm
gonna go get your tour guides I was
expecting a person you're gonna have
some nice friendly little people maybe
an Eskimo or two to take us around the
city ladies meet the Black Jack - your
only connection to the outside world
which you'll be using to document your
journey mine was pink and I really like
pink I'm almost glad that we ended up
with these phones as tour guides I mean
I can't take pictures with a human this
takes pictures and video and it has GPS
we'll be sending you challenges on these
and as you complete them you'll receive
new clues as to where you're headed good
luck it's gonna be a piece of cake cuz
you know Jesse and I together we can
figure anything out oh one more thing
you'll be separated put these on
are you serious in sane just crazy cuz
I'm kind of excited alone lost and alone
great oh look I can't see anything
ha well how am I even supposed to see
this at a pond it just pushes the button
and I really was the biggest blindfold
I've ever seen in my life not that I see
those often but it was pretty big all
right let's get going I can't believe
they were gonna drop us off in the
milled nowhere I started eating so
nervous my hands were getting all sweaty
good luck take your blindfold off now
so the van pulled away and a little bit
scared at first I thought maybe I would
run after it and be like no I changed my
mind
GPS tells me that I'm in Anchorage oh
right down over there get it no wait
that was a bird when it's really far
away in the water it's kind of it's hard
to tell I got the text with my first set
of challenges have coffee with a local
but I'm still all alone and find a local
I would never Justine is I hope she's
okay
I'm literally pushed out of a van I
don't know if you've ever been pushed
out of a band before but it's pretty
scary especially being blindfolded good
luck
I turn around there's like mountains and
river lake forest stuff and thankfully
had this little guy so the GPS was like
yo what's up you're an Anchorage Alaska
Oh first challenge have coffee with a
local I'm even think phones worked up
here apparently they work quite well
my first challenge was to have coffee
with a local take a picture and then
upload it hi how are you doing would you
mind if I take a seat we had a great
conversation so uh do you live here
together and I uploaded that well thank
you so much Judy's meet you Tracy
mission accomplished
coffee with a local Oh perfect
so I found a coffee shop found a local
took a picture of him we had coffee and
he forced me to play chess with him
I don't know if he knew that I had a
mission to complete
but he thought I'd sit there all day and
play chess cute man but let me tell you
he likes to play chess probably do this
or you can move your king the other side
of the world I want you to do well what
I think I mean I have to go and finish
my challenges I have coffee with a local
done
my next challenge was to take a picture
of a caribou or a moose and then upload
it I'm not even sure what a caribou is
oh oh there's one there's a moose oh
it's blue I stumbled upon this blue
moose totem pole and I figured it counts
it was the moose gotta take a picture
good challenge completed challenge
number two
done where am I gonna find a caribou at
I don't even what a caribou looks like
and a moose yeah messy messy messy I
literally was running around in the
streets running around in the forest
trying to find a moose now I don't know
if you know or not but these moose are
huge they're ridiculously huge
my next challenge was to show full bars
and once I saw them I just wanted to
share it with this other woman and when
I look up I realized that she wasn't
actually a real person but she did
remind me of somebody for some reason in
Anchorage Alaska there is a statue of me
so you know while looking for this moose
I get completely lost and we're on a
time deadline here and if we don't make
it we're not gonna be able to get into
the event so this moose this is crucial
that I find this and I get completely
lost I was just so far away from
everything that I literally thought that
I might have to find a moose just to get
dinner
I have never been so frustrated I just
don't think I can even continue